the Chinese called it Black Monday this
week began with China's stock market
losing 8.5 percent of its value the
biggest drop since 2007 then the rest of
the world woke up and things got brutal
before partially recovering on Tuesday
Europe's 300 biggest companies dropped
in value by more than 260 billion
dollars in the US the stock indexes had
their biggest drop since the global
financial crisis of 2008 but why is the
Chinese economy affecting the rest of
the world
well many companies including lots of
American ones like Apple's manufacture
their products in China they also sell
those products to Chinese consumers then
you have countries that sell commodities
like coal metals and oil that thrive off
of Chinese demand so when China's
economy slows down as it has been for
the past few years now the rest of the
world feels it one of the ways China's
government has tried to boost its
economy is by allowing ordinary Chinese
people to start borrowing money to buy
stocks that sent the price of tiny
stocks soaring much higher than what
they're actually worth but since June
those overvalued stock prices have been
dropping and now the bubbles burst
investors around the world including in
the u.s. took a look at what's happening
in China and started to panic wondering
could this happen here too when
investors panic they sell their stocks
that's why other financial markets took
such a beating so is this the start of
another global financial crisis well
probably not the stock market is not the
economy and while stocks dropping might
sometimes indicate economic downturn
other times it's just stocks acting like
they do they go up and down depending on
profit forecasts but forget about all
the jargon how does this actually affect
you well unless you're rich you're
probably not a big investor in the stock
market only about a quarter of folks
under 30 even own stocks those that do
might have them in a pension plan like a
401 K those might be affected in the
short term but you should remember that
these are long-term investments as
economist Dean Baker told us unless you
happen to buy
yesterday by last week can be selling
today most people are still way up in
the stock they own so in other words if
you'd bought stock a year ago tears ago
it's selling for much more today at
least on average Baker also says lower
stock prices might actually be good for
us young folks because if we do want to
invest in the future lower prices could
mean higher returns so don't panic just
yet but since China is the world's
second biggest economy we'd all be wise
to keep an eye on what's happening there